so ice cream cakes have been my thing  since practically birth every year for  my birthday I've gotten an ice cream  cake from the local Baskin Robbins and  now as an adult whenever I have a chance  to bring something to a party I always  bring ice cream cake or some type of  dessert and to be honest I had to make a  cake using one of my favorites and a  childhood classic ice cream bar  Strawberry Shortcake all you need is  store-bought pound cake your favorite  softened ice cream or ice cream bars  Cool Whip and whatever crumbled garnish  you want obviously my apartment was too  hot so make sure your ice cream is just  off and not pelted which ice cream  flavor should I try next